hey Mary here once again to talk to you
bout the latest games coming out this
week in new releases and this week you
get updated laura croft models maybe
she's born with it maybe it's Tomb
Raider definitive edition just look at
those tressfx improved weapon physics
and skin drip maps that really shine in
the sweat mud and blood that surround
Laura it's also 60 FPS on the ps4 but
only 30 on the Xbox one too fast soak in
that glorious texture resolution January
28 also this week you can create a team
goku's and dragon ball z battle of z or
is it a team of kakarot play with up to
four players co-op and choose from over
70 characters each with power levels
over 9000 I got dibs on Crillon because
I only like to use solar flare Mayim a
ha January 28 also this week you can put
together your best weapons and your
favorite deadly combinations to kill
your closest friends in loadout finally
coming out of early access and into
official game status think team fortress
but with way more dancing and obscure
nudity nice let it all hang out January
31st this week also gives us chapter one
of the highly anticipated graphic
adventure broken age broken age started
out as a humble Kickstarter but then
made millions that was used to purchase
important people like wil wheaton jack
black jennifer hale and elijah wood to
create a star-studded cast resembling
that of a pixar film combine that with
the brain of Tim Schafer and
hand-painted 2d art this game is pretty
much a win-win broken age comes out
january twenty eighth
finally the castle doctrine created by
developer jason rohrer comes out on pc
this week up your home defenses and keep
your family and money safe while
breaking into other people's homes and
killing their families oh this is pretty
dark well there's some other games worth
mentioning to like strike vector where
you play as a brutal airship pilot or
octodad where you play as a cephalopod
mullis with offspring or ribbon could
dip seville where you command a space
station and its minions to learn how to
pronounce the name rim de capsule for
further details visit gamespot's new
releases page release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change see you next week